[Musique]
je
joe biden et les administrateurs système
de l'état profond et de l' empire
retrouve le pouvoir
donald trump et sa clique de bouffons
des secours assistés de chrétiens
fascistes des centres de l'olympe la
tête basse
l'amérique est de retour selon mme
hayden prêt à reprendre sa place pour
présider dans la bataille pour l'âme de
l'amérique nous assure-t-il
la démocratie a repris le dessus selon
lui le progrès la prospérité la civilité
la confirmation du prestige et du
pouvoir américain frappe à la porte
cependant toutes les nominations de
byden relève de cercle démocrates et des
élites du monde des affaires de ce don
qui sont responsables des flagrantes
inégalités sociales des accords
commerciaux de la désindustrialisation
de la militarisation de la police du
plus vaste système pénitentiaire du
monde des mesures d'austérité ayant mené
à l'abandon des programmes de sécurité
sociale de la reprise de la guerre
froide avec la russie de la surveillance
gouvernementale à grande échelle des
guerres incessantes au moyen-orient de
la marginalisation et de
l'appauvrissement de la classe ouvrière
selon le washington post près de 80% des
fonctionnaires annoncé pour reprendre
des postes à la maison blanche où dans
le gouvernement ont le mot obama sur
leur cv
après avoir travaillé dans
l'administration pour la campagne
électorale d'obama l'administration
byden ressemble à l'esn efficace
gouvernement allemand de franzen papen
de 1932 ce gouvernement cherchait à
restaurer l'ancien régime et ce
conservatisme utopique a poussé
l'allemagne a sombré dans le fascisme
bernie sanders qui n'a pu obtenir le
poste de secrétaire au travail dans
l'administration maiden s'est dit
frustré par les nomination du nouveau
président
l'élu alexandra occasion cortese n'a pas
été nommé à la commission de l'énergie
et du commerce en raison de son soutien
au green new deal l'administration
byetone envoie un message très clair aux
progressistes et populiste de gauche
dégagé que signifie la décision de
l'administration byden d'offrir un
troisième mandat l'administration obama
pour un pays en crise ravagé par une
épidémie qu'il ne peut maîtriser un pays
pris en otage par le monde des affaires
est divisé en factions rivales le
journaliste est lauréat du prix
pullitzer glenn greenwald me rejoint
pour discuter de la nouvelle
administration buydens alors glen nous
avons vu les nominations nous savons
d'où viennent ces gens victoria nuland
susan rice
lloyd austin du conseil d'administration
du racing
janet yellen qu'attendez-vous de
l'administration baden et pourquoi je
suppose que vous partagez mon avis sur
ce point elle est probablement
dangereuse je ne pense pas qu'il soit
particulièrement difficile où laborieux
de comprendre à quoi faut-il s'attendre
de l'administration buydens en partie
parce que joe biden est un politique au
niveau national depuis 1972
il s'agit là d'une cinquantaine d'années
qui le caractérise de manière assez
explicite
c'est un fidèle partisan du militarisme
et de l'impérialisme
il a été l'un des plus grands défenseurs
de l'invasion de l'irak en sa qualité de
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat en 2002 venant du
deleware il a été le fidèle serviteur
des banques et des services de cartes de
crédit c'est l'auteur du projet de la
loi qui a tellement exaspéré elizabeth
warren qu'elle en est venu à entrer en
politique
il s'agit du projet de loi qui a rendu
beaucoup plus difficile pour les
consommateurs en faillite de se
débarrasser de leur dette
il est de toute évidence est derrière le
projet de loi contre le crime
en 1994 il ya quelque chose de tout à
fait ironique cette année et nous avons
connu des mois et des mois de
manifestations essentiellement de la
part de la gauche contre l'état policier
et les abus raciste de la police et
c'est la personne qui en est peut-être
la plus responsable que ces gens ont
choisi de soutenir
ajoutons à cela les huit ans de
l'administration obama home by john
était un élément clé et qui laissait
délibérément de reproduire
comme vous l'avez noté je pense que les
gens ont oublié ce que c'était que
l'administration obama
les démocrates sont très doués pour
créer une façade qui est radicalement
différente de leur réalité
la vérité est que le parti démocrate
sert le militarisme l'impérialisme et le
corporatisme
c'est la source de leur financement est
le fondement de leur croyance
c'est pour cette raison qu'on voit des
néoconservateurs migrer aussi facilement
vers le parti démocrate
c'est pourquoi des fonctionnaires de
l'époque de bush cheney à claudio by day
et c'est pourquoi wall street a célébré
la nomination de kamala harris qui a
bien sûr son propre parcours de
procureur intransigeant
je pense qu'il est très facile de voir
qui ces gens sont exactement
d'après vous quelles seront les
conséquences de tout cela pour un pays
en crise il y a un point de vue assez
fort avec lequel je pense être en accord
c'est en grande partie l'échec de
l'administration obama qui n'a pas su
résoudre les problèmes systémiques qui a
causé l'apparition de donald trump et du
trump isme quel est le danger de
poursuivre ce genre de politiques
néolibérales
je pense que vous voyez les dangers
qu'implique cette mentalité cette
idéologie néolibérale pas seulement aux
états unis mais à travers le monde
démocratique
ici au brésil où je vis les gens me
demande tout le temps comment est il
possible qu'un pays qui a voté pour un
parti ouvrier de centre gauche de 2002 à
2014 donc pendant quatre scrutins
nationaux consécutifs et soudain penché
vers l'extrémisme d'extrême droite de
vieillir box hoarau la réponse est que
le système a échoué
ils savent que le système a échoué et
ils ont opté pour quelqu'un qui leur
semblait être l'adversaire le plus
virulent de cet ordre politique
évidemment cela est aussi valable pour
le break sites au royaume uni et pour la
montée en puissance des partis d'extrême
droite en europe de l'ouest des endroits
où on ne se serait jamais attendu à les
voir fleurir et ce n'est pas une
coïncidence si après huit ans de mama et
de bail donne nous nous sommes retrouvés
avec donald trump
bien sûr si vous fait marche arrière et
reprenait exactement le même chemin que
lors des huit années de l'administration
obama
et c'est ce que byron s'apprête à faire
tout esprit rationnel doit s'attendre à
ce que le résultat soit le même c'est à
dire un retour l'anéantissement de la
classe moyenne avec des entreprises sans
aucune loyauté envers les états unis qui
ré expatrient rond autant d'emplois que
possible dans des endroits où elles
peuvent utiliser une madame
qui ne coûte rien nous allons continuer
à faire ça les communautés vont être
ravagée par le chômage la drogue le
suicide est la dépression
toutes ces choses qui prévalent dans les
petites villes et villages américains et
même de plus en plus dans les grandes
villes
la colère et le mécontentement ne feront
que grandir
par conséquent dès qu'on aura une
version plus fine plus stable de donald
trump qui voudraient exploiter cette
colère et permettra de fermer les états
unis d'améliorer la vie des gens
ce sera encore plus séduisant pour ces
gens l'administration by day notamment
si on considère certains de ceux qui ont
été nommés a clairement fait comprendre
qu'elle voyait les le progressiste du
parti démocrate organisées autour de
bernie sanders comme un ennemi
beaucoup de ceux que biden a nommé
ridiculise ouvertement sanders et ses
partisans
qu'est ce que cela implique pour le
parti et pour les progressistes et bien
c'est une dynamique très intéressante et
pathétique a observé parce que l'une des
stratégies de joe biden quand il faisait
campagne contre trump et est de dénigrer
bernie sanders et la gauche aussi
souvent que possible et de constamment
ridiculiser trump quand ce dernier
essayait de faire le lien entre lui et
bernie occasion cortès inédit qui
répondent aux doux le green new deal en
disant je les ai détruit écrasé et ce
n'est pas moi vous me prenez pour
quelqu'un d'autre
joe biden a toujours eu du mépris pour
la gauche tout comme barack obama mais
et bizarrement plus ce mépris devient
flagrant ouvert et profond et plus la
gauche soumet au cours des dernières
années j'ai entendu des gens non
seulement tolérés mais loué la stratégie
de bail donne de prendre ses distances
avec bernie disant que c'était la chose
la plus avisée la plus sage à faire une
fois l'élection terminée et bernie
n'avait aucune chance de devenir
secrétaire au travail alors qu'il a
pratiquement mendier pour obtenir ce
poste
ils ont trouvé comme excuse qu'il valait
mieux qu'il reste au sénat comme berne
il a dit lui même il n'y a pas vraiment
de progressistes parmi les personnes
nommées
on peut si on élargit la définition
à considérer un ou deux postes de peu
d'importance mais de toute évidence
personne de ceux qui peuvent être
associés à la mouvance sanders qui était
devenue la force dominante dans le parti
démocrate entre 2016 et 2020 ne fait
partie de cette administration
je ne vois que très peu de contestations
de la part de la gauche parce qu'ils ont
adhéré à ce récit selon lequel il n'y a
que deux possibilités se rallier au sein
du parti démocrate et combattre le
fascisme et hitler ou se soumettre au
fascisme
cela ressemble à la stratégie de bachar
el-assad en syrie qui est celle de dire
je sais que vous me détestez
mais vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
de vous rallier à moi ou d'être
gouvernés par des ch
c'est la tactique qu'il emploie et à
part quelques exceptions à gauche ça
semble marcher je pense que la loyauté
de la gauche envers le parti démocrate
n'a pas été aussi forte depuis longtemps
je voudrais qu'on discute du problème de
la censure nous avons vu la gauche
totalement accepté la censure massive de
la part de la silicon valley et pas
uniquement maintenant avec le cas par
leur bail donne se prononce en faveur
d'une nouvelle loi anti terroriste lui
qui était déjà parmi les principaux
inspirateurs du patriot act
mais même avant l'élection commençons
par là twitter a bloqué le compte du new
york post est votre article sur les
données trouvées dans l'ordinateur de
hunter biden a fait l'objet d'une
censure et ont finalement été retirée de
intercepte vous en avez démissionné
alors que vous étiez parmi les
fondateurs du média mais bon avant et
pendant la campagne
la gauche a fait l'éloge de tout cela
est l'une des grandes causes de la
gauche lors de la campagne électorale de
2020 et que je soutenais d'ailleurs
consistait à aider ed markey
longtemps membre du congrès est
maintenant sénateur du massachussetts à
vaincre son challenger nominalement de
droite
le membre du congrès de joe kennedy 3
dans la primaire démocrate mark est il
devenu un héros de la gauche et après sa
victoire à la primaire
audition ait lieu une audition à
laquelle les principaux acteurs de la
silicon valley dont mark zuckerberg ont
été convoqués pour témoigner devant la
commission
et le sénateur mark et en faisait partie
alors il a dit à marc zuckerberg
contrairement à mes collègues du parti
républicain qui se plaignent de la
censure nous ne croyons pas que vous
censurez trop nous croyons que vous ne
censurez pas assez ensuite il lui a
montré quelques exemples de propos sur
facebook que marc est considéré comme
dangereux ou extrémistes et qui la
demandaient de censurer
obama a fait un discours quelques mois
avant l'élection dans lequel il
qualifiait internet de plus grande
menace pour la démocratie américaine à
cause du rôle qu'il joue dans la
désinformation
ainsi au sein du parti démocrate sur son
aile libérale comme sur son aile gauche
l'idée est largement admise qu'il est
impossible d'avoir la liberté de la
parole en cette époque de suprématisme
blanc de terrorisme intérieur d
extrémisme de droite peu importe comment
ils appellent ça car c'est simplement
trop dangereux et que non seulement il
faudrait restreindre la liberté
d'expression par des lois adoptées par
le congrès ce qui signifierait qu'il est
nécessaire de modifier le premier
amendement
mais jusque là ils ont été à genoux
suppliant les milliardaires les
oligarques et les monopoles east de la
silicon valley il exercer une censure
d'une manière qui leur soit
politiquement avantageuse et comme vous
l'avez dit et c'était le cas même avant
l'élection honnêtement je pense crise
que l'un des moments les plus importants
de ces cinq ou six dernières années a
été quand le new york post a commencé à
publier des articles sur des documents
qui aujourd'hui tout le monde le
reconnaît était absolument authentiques
la communauté du renseignement a inventé
un mensonge selon lequel il s'agissait
de désinformation russe ce qui a
immédiatement mis la pression ou à
donner le prétexte à twitter et à
facebook de censurer l'article
si vous vouliez aller sur twitter et
poster un lien vers l'article du new
york post concernant l'ordinateur de
hunter by donne qui contenait beaucoup
d'informations sur les activités de joe
biden en ukraine sur ses activités en
chine
quand il était favori dans la course à
la présidence il était impossible de le
faire de poster ce lien il l'avait
censuré facebook a annoncé via un ancien
démocrate qui travaille maintenant pour
facebook qu'il allait étouffer la
propagation de cette histoire par le
biais d'un algorithme c'est une
incroyable intervention de la part de la
silicon valley dans la pratique du
journalisme dans l'élection au bénéfice
du candidat qu'elle soutenait à fond
et puisque les démocrates ont gagné
chaque fois qu'il s'adresse à apple
google facebook ou twitter pour censurer
ces entreprises obtempère parce qu'ils
marchent main dans la main parce qu'il
ya une alliance entre les milliardaires
les oligarques où les monopoliste de la
silicon valley d'un côté et le parti
démocrate de l'autre et tout cela va
maintenant fusionné avec le pouvoir de
l'état
d'accord à notre retour nous
poursuivrons notre conversation sur la
nouvelle administration maiden avec le
lauréat du prix pullitzer glenn
greenwald
[Musique]
vous êtes toujours avec nous et nous
poursuivons notre conversation sur la
nouvelle administration by donne avec le
lauréat du prix pullitzer glenn
greenwald alors glen parlons du
bannissement de donald trump des réseaux
sociaux et même d'un réseau commercial
pourquoi cela constitue-t-il un
précédent dangereux
j'ai trouvé vraiment intéressant le fait
que de nombreux leaders mondiaux y
compris ceux qui sont connus pour leurs
mauvaises relations avec donald trump
est vivement critiqué la décision de
twitter et de facebook de bannir tron
des réseaux sociaux
il s'agit notamment de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel une politique de
centre droit avec itron n'a cessé de
s'embrouiller tout au long de son mandat
il s'agit du président mexicain lopez
obrador un politique de gauche qui a mis
en garde de manière éloquente quant au
fait que la silicon valley devenait le
leader médiatique mondiale quelque chose
de supérieur aux états nationaux des
ministres du gouvernement français qui
évidemment n'aime pas non plus donald
trump ont également et dans le même
terme dénoncer ce qui s'était passé
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont extrêmement
préoccupés par le fait que ces monopoles
technologie privée et ne peuvent pas
être défiée lui a essayé de lutter
contre google et facebook pendant des
années mais il n'y arrive pas tout
simplement parce que ces entreprises
sont trop puissantes et pénètre dans
leur démocratie et ils savent que si
facebook ou twitter peut bannir donald
trump d'internet la même chose peut être
fait vis-à-vis d'eux mêmes dans leur
propre pays
les seuls que cela ne dérange pas sont
semble-t-il les libéraux américains et
je pense que l'incident le plus
inquiétant au delà de celui dont nous
avons précédemment parlé quand facebook
et twitter ont joint leurs efforts pour
bloquer une publication du new york post
et le fait que amazon apple
google trois des quatre grandes sociétés
que la sous commission antitrust
démocrates du congrès avait déclaré
monopoliste dangereuse et
anticoncurrentielles dans un rapport
exhaustif publié il ya seulement trois
mois se sont unis pour chasser
d'internet un concurrent de facebook
twitter et instagram qui était devenu
l'application la plus téléchargée sur
l'apple store parleurs se justifiant en
invoquant le rôle joué par parleurs dans
l'assaut sur le capitole et les émeutes
qui ont eu lieu le 6 janvier
et ceci malgré le fait que leurs propres
services tels que youtube et facebook et
ont joué un rôle beaucoup plus important
ils ont tout simplement détruit une
plateforme concurrente à la demande de
jean comme les membres du congrès rock
anna et alexandria occasion cortès ils
ont publié des demandes sur twitter et
en l'espace de 72 heures par leurs
n'existait plus sur internet
donc il n'est pas très difficile de
comprendre pourquoi il est très
dangereux que notre parole notre
capacité à nous organiser sur internet
et à être entendus soit concentré entre
les mains d'une poignée d'oligarques de
la silicon valley qui sortent
complètement du cadre des responsabilité
démocratique et dont l'activité n'est ni
transparentes ni limitée par quoi que ce
soit dans votre dernier papier puisque
je vous suis vous avez justement évoqué
le sujet de par leur donner aux gens une
idée de comment s'abonner à vos
publications sur ce post ac oui alors ce
obstacle c'est l'une des nouvelles
plateformes indépendantes qui permet aux
gens d'écrire et de communiquer sans
interférence du moins pour le moment
j'ai quitté de intercepte et je me suis
rabattu sur cette plateforme
vous pouvez trouver mes publications sur
green moule point s'obstine point com et
il ya d'autres auteurs comme par exemple
ma taibi sur tie bi poin obstacles coin
comme qui font un travail exceptionnel
et j'appelle les gens à soutenir les
médias indépendants
c'est l'un des remèdes essentielle à
tout cela parlons un peu de ce que
avec les puissants outils qui sont à
leur disposition n'oublions pas que la
silicon valley a été l'un des principaux
sponsors de la campagne de baden et a
produit une série de publicités anti
trump au cours de la dernière semaine de
la campagne
tout cela à l'aide d'argent venant d'un
super comité d'action politique buy
donne à une est animosité envers les
progressistes et la gauche
si l'administration by donne poursuit la
politique d administration clinton obama
et ne parvient pas à faire face à la
destruction des liens sociaux au
grotesque inégalités sociales et à la
misère qui a été infligée exacerbée par
les retombées économiques de la pandémie
que va-t-il arriver d'après vous à des
voix comme la vôtre ou celle de matt
taibbi que va-t-il arriver aux critiques
progressiste qui met à jour le vrai
visage des démocrates
je pense qu'ils sont très attachés à
l'idée de détruire tout média permettant
des voisins dépendante de la dissidence
de s'exprimer déjà vous pouvez tout
simplement consulté le new york times de
ce matin il y à un article qui explique
que les gens qui utilisaient parleur
mais qui ne le peuvent plus maintenant
parce qu'il a été chassé d'internet par
amazon google et apple migrent vers les
plateformes quelques télégrammes et
signal et donc il y à un article du new
york times qui pose les jalons de la
rhétorique suivante regarder et
télégramme et signale sont maintenant
des lieux d'expression pour ces
extrémisme de droite qui est devenu si
dangereux biz
ce n'est qu'une question de temps alors
que ce stock se développe
avant que ces groupes de journaliste de
nbc du new york times et de cnn dont la
seule fonction est d'exiger la censure
commence à s'en prendre à des
plateformes comme son stack ou pas très
bonne en disant regardez c'est un refuge
pour l'extrémisme pourquoi ne supprime
t-il pas ce contenu ce sont des
extrémistes et des radicalise et c'est
très dangereux
il veut garder le monopole de la
diffusion de l'information est le plus
choquant est que ce sont des
journalistes qui dirige cette croisade
pour la censure des journalistes
qui travaillent dans de grands médias ce
sont eux qui prône le plus la censure
car ils ne veulent pas que d'autres voix
rivalise avec la leur vous dites dans
l'une de vos publications que la raison
d'être de tout cela nous parlons de
médias comme le new york times et le
fait qu'il se positionne comme étant
neutres mais vous démontrer en quelque
sorte cet argument expliquez-nous cela
l'idée que les médias biaisé qu'ils
soient de la gauche de la droite sont
fermées ou censurés et on prend la
direction suivante les gens qui
cherchent des informations sont dirigés
vers certains médias classiques comme le
new york times comme s'il était objectif
mais expliquez nous s'il vous plaît
pourquoi ces faux et bien de toute
évidence il y environ 15 ans est apparue
une question liée à l'avènement
d'internet
cette question est comment les médias et
les journaux peuvent ils survivre alors
qu'il ya tant de contenus gratuits en
ligne grâce à internet
d'où peuvent ils tirer leurs revenus
auparavant ils pouvaient remplir leurs
caisses grâce à des annonces
publicitaires
mais les annonceurs se tournent
désormais principalement vers google ou
facebook qui collectent entre 90 et 95%
de ce qui était auparavant le gain
publicitaires des médias traditionnels
les gens ont été de moins en moins
disposés à payer pour un contenu en
ligne et ses médias et est donc en
grande difficulté alors ils ont adopté
un nouveau modèle pour rester
financièrement viable un modèle qui
consistait à dire nous ne sommes pas
seulement des diffuseurs d'information
objectif parce que vous pouvez obtenir
cela n'importe où mais nous allons être
dévoué à une cause politique
particulière et puisque cette cause vous
tient tellement à coeur vous allez nous
donner votre argent de la même manière
que vous le donne aurier à l'union
américaine pour les libertés civiles ou
un autre groupe que vous sous plus ainsi
le new york times cnn
ms nbc et tous ces autres médias se sont
positionnés comme média en titre up et
tous ceux qui l'ont fait visait
principalement à apaiser et a loué le
parti démocrate dont les partisans sont
devenus
leur public le public démocrate est
désormais celui de la classe
gestionnaire blanche
c'est ainsi qu'ils obtiennent l'argent
des abonnements en raison de cette
incitation financière à devenir au fonds
des organismes ou des porte parole du
parti démocrate
évidemment pas de l'ale socialiste du
parti mais celle de l'établissment
néolibérale et pourtant ils affirment
être neutres
c'est l'argument qu'ils avancent pour
attirer des lecteurs vers leurs contenus
oui c'est un peu ironique car quand j'ai
commencé à écrire sur la politique en
l'une de mes motivations étaient le fait
que je pensais que ce genre de pseudo
neutralité de pseudo objectivité que les
médias avaient depuis longtemps adopté
comme méthode détruisait le journalisme
l'exemple qui m'a le plus choqué à
l'époque était que l'administration bush
ait commencé à mettre en oeuvre un
système de torture dans le monde entier
et que les médias refusent de parler de
torture au motif que l'administration
bush cheney qu'il s'agisse de torture
les groupes de défense des droits de
l'homme
le monde entier disait que c'était de la
torture qui sommes nous pour décider si
nous ne sommes que des journalistes
nous vous transmettons ce que dit une
partie puis ce que dit l'autre partie
puis nous nous en lavant les mains
c'était clairement une forme corruptrice
de journalisme car elle excluait la
vérité alors que moi je préconisais une
forme de journalisme plus accusatoire et
honnête c'est à dire ne pas avoir peur
d'appeler mensonges les mensonges des
fonctionnaires du gouvernement
dans un sens ils ont adopté cette
approche mais seulement dans un sens
très partisan ils ne sont pas prêts à
agir de la sorte que quand il s'agit de
donald trump
parce que c'est tout ce que leur
électorat veut entendre vous allez voir
un changement radical dans la façon dont
le gouvernement américain va être
couverts maintenant alors qu'abidal et
les démocrates prennent le relais je
parie que le nombre de fois où à l'écran
de cnn on qualifiera une déclaration
d'attaché de presse ou une déclaration
du président ou du vice président de man
ange ou de fausses vont se compter sur
les doigts d'une main
parce qu'ils ne font pas de journalisme
ils font de l'activisme au bénéfice du
parti démocrate
c'est ça le modèle qu'ils ont adoptée
très bien c'était ce que pense le
journaliste est lauréat du prix
pullitzer glenn greenwald de ce que nous
réserve la nouvelle administration byden
merci glenn marci crise
[Musique]
oui